[Music]
author stephen pressfield's books have
earned him worldwide acclaim
from gates of fire to the legend of
bagger vance and the war of art
pressfield has written both fiction and
nonfiction
books that reach back thousands of years
and ones that deal with the struggles of
our modern times
some of the stories you've seen on the
big screen and maybe soon his latest
called the man at arms
but his personal story is just as
inspiring
i think of this book as like an american
western
even though it's set in the first
century a.d stephen pressfield
joined us via cross-country call the sun
and sand
of malibu on one end snow in connecticut
on the other
our common ground the sinai desert
setting of a man at arms in the first
century a.d
shortly after the crucifixion of jesus
the main character of pressfield's
latest book
is a soldier of fortune named telemon of
arcadia
living during the roman occupation of
jerusalem and the holy lands
and plucked in the middle of an epic
tale of heroism
and betrayal the character of taliman is
a character that i've had in three other
books
he's like my only recurring character
and
he's kind of a fascinating character to
me a little bit of an alter ego for me
so i wanted to write this book to follow
his journey and just see where he was
going
telemon's journey is an expansion of
recurring theme
in pressfield's work people engaged in
monumental struggles against others
and themselves you wrote for how long
before you found success
i think it was 28 years i was trying to
write
and uh you know some friends of mine
called me the man who has written more
words for
less money than anybody on the planet
including as an advertising copywriter
just one part
of a dizzying life pressfield was born
in trinidad in 1943 while his father was
stationed in the navy
after graduating from duke he served in
the marines
before taking jobs as a bartender
teacher
trucker and fruit picker 21
jobs overall in 11 states meanwhile the
writing rejections kept rolling in
was there a lowest point at one point i
was in new york driving a cab
dead broke living just me and my cat
in this apartment and i didn't know what
else to do you know i was wondering
whether i should
hang myself or blow my brains out and
and how that would affect my poor cat
but here's the positive side of that for
whatever this is worth after a few days
of like utter agony
i said to myself why don't i go to
hollywood
and try to be a screenwriter
screenwriting including the forgettable
king kong lives didn't really work out
but finally book writing did pressfield
published his first at the age of 52
the fantastic the legend of bagger vance
later made a movie with matt damon
charlize theron
and will smith i could have killed you
out there oh no sir see i set myself
directly in front of you
judging by how you was hitting them
balls i figured that's why i'd be out of
harm's way
an even more famous novel followed
1998's
gates of fire about the battle of
thermopylae in ancient greece
one of our all-time favorites what do
you think it is about gates of fire
that means so much to so many people now
still
20 years after it was published that
historical event
is such a pure expression of the warrior
ethos it was a
purely defensive battle so there was
nothing wrong about it nothing
no conquest elements to it it was
against overwhelming odds
and it was for a great cause you know to
save
western civilization since gates of fire
pressfield is alternated between
historical fiction
and non-fiction books of guidance and
inspiration
the best one 2002's the war of art
focusing on resistance resistance with a
capital r
is that negative force that will try to
stop us
from moving from a lower level to a
higher level
self-sabotage fear arrogance complacency
procrastination and to me the number one
thing that any writer or artist needs to
know
is they've got to overcome that force
one way or another
before they can do anything like i say
it's not the writing that's the hard
part
it's the sitting down to write
pressfield has done that and now has 18
books to show for it
[Music]
for the past year during the pandemic
he's tackled yet another project
a series of 50 youtube videos on the
ancient
warrior archetype focusing on courage
selflessness
and the willing embrace of adversity
when i start the morning
with something hard and something
physical i've got a real head start on
my day
it's the kind of thing in these times
these are virtues that it's great to
to reinforce in ourselves and to hang on
to
because we're not getting the external
feedback that we might get if we went
into an office we went into a workplace
if we had a boss that is rewarding us or
kicking our butt you know
instead we have to do that all ourselves
and it's all internal
it's tough sometimes for people given
how insane
the last year has been to take lessons
from thousands of years ago but they're
important
i mean i think in many ways we're
desperate for those lessons
and we because we can't really find them
here
you know i don't i don't want to get too
political but you know that if we look
at the senate and the congress right now
we've been searching very very hard for
honor and people are hungry for that
and they want it in their own lives and
so that's why i think it's certainly why
i'm
drawn to the ancient past well that's
the best part about your books they're
not about politicians they're about
warriors
i mean that's what i'm hoping to do
there's always been this interesting
split between people who love his
historical novels like gates of fire and
those who love the inspirational books
like the war of art i've always liked
both um but if you get a chance
i mean a man at arms his latest it's
just fun it's interesting relief
reading during these times to pick up
something that has anything to do with
something that's currently happening
he seems like such an affable guy yeah
he's great yeah
appreciating success that came later i
want to know he had the cat then if he
has cats now the cat that saved his life
i don't know actually i'll have to ask
him obviously that cat no longer that
cat is probably many many years ago yeah